>> One of the most exciting things I'm looking
forward to in the next 5
to 10 years is the development of cheap, affordable
education which can
be delivered by, brought back by Internet,
by mobile phones, by many
different techniques to the masses of the
world, particularly in the
emerging economies.
Countries like India and China, which need
affordable education very,
very badly.
And yet the cost of that education today and
the way it's delivered, is
completely outmoded.
It's not in sync with technology; it's not
in sync with the [INAUDIBLE]
most importantly it's not in sync with the
way people would want to get
educated.
So can we deliver education?
Can we deliver skills development at $50 a
course?
Can we deliver better courses at $100 a course?
Can we deliver graduate programs at $500 a
course?
That development is happening.
A lot of people are working on it.
They're working on both content and delivery
and cost.
If we can get it down to that affordable level,
I think it will be one
of the most exciting developments the world
could ever have.
Because it would transform the way more of
the world thinks, and it
will make them become a lot more inclusive
with the rest of the world
economy.